the jurogan experience it's like a
boxing like turning with the punch
exactly that's all i got left exactly
i'm gonna turn my jaw as you punch it
yeah some guys are masters at that [ __ ]
yeah you stand right in front of dudes
and let them throw punches
yeah canelo it was really improved god
it's so funny to see him like because i
was at the fight where canelo
fought mayweather and like you do
remember that fight yeah
and just mayweather just totally
schooled him man it was it was
unbelievable
truly unbelievable to even just be there
in that room and just watch there was so
much confidence behind canelo right and
obviously like
80 percent of the crowd was mexican
right and you saw like 80 percent of
crowds hearts just broken
because by the third round you know
exactly what's going on it was just this
complete domination
and yeah man it was unbelievable to see
mayweather's a real master he's a modern
master to me he's the greatest great of
all time
meaning he's greater at boxing than like
stephen hawking is at science
in my opinion there's a good argument
for that because who's come close
here's the thing like the the sport is
hit and not be hit
who does that better than floyd
mayweather dude i can name three times
in his career
where he was hurt i can name them yeah
zab judah right hook shane mosley
demarcus chop chop corley demarcus jobs
have corley almost like put him out
and it was the same about that fight how
about my donna
my daughter yeah my don hit him at the
end of a yeah at the end of the belly
hit him in the right hand and floyd
didn't know where his corner was for a
second he was out of it but he's got a
beard that's the thing about freud a lot
of people don't realize that he's got
the pretty boy [ __ ] but he could take a
shot
yeah and i remember just like i'm like
damn this guy is impossible to beat
what do you think is going to happen
when he fights logan paul how crazy is
that
dude i love dude i like logan logan's a
big
kid but it's a big it doesn't matter
it's like canelo was big
they've all been busy but you know with
canelo that floyd one of the things he
did that was really intelligent
he forced canelo to go down to i believe
it was 150 154 ounces
oh did they have a catch weight yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think he did that because he knew
canelo had a hard time making 154. yeah
yeah i mean now canelo's at 168.
well he fought 75. he knocked out
kovalev i thought that was a 168 no that
was the light i was the lightheaded
yeah yeah he knocked out kovalev yeah
yeah great left hook yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but i mean look
at this i mean that's obviously not real
but still
logan's got the size he's a big guy real
but it
might be close and floyd is tiny but the
same time it's like
logan's not gonna hit floyd with any
shot that he hasn't been hit with before
the only way he could is if you got a
bad referee
and the referee lets them tie up so if
the referee lets him
lets logan tie him up yup and
logan can hit floyd in the clinch right
hurt him
i don't think that can he generate that
much power
you a guy who's strong who can hit hard
can [ __ ] you up from a clinch it happens
all the time
yeah but dc knocked out stipe from the
clinch
yeah yeah that was that short right hand
yeah really nice
yeah i just i don't see anybody doing
that to floyd man like
if you watch floyd's sparring stuff do
you ever watch his like
the mayweather gym stuff amazing 15
minute rounds 15 minute rounds and
in the gym heat is not on his bicycle in
the gym he is
in front of you talking [ __ ] as you miss
every single shot you throw at him yeah
and it's like there's no way that logan
connects
what i think could happen is that the
fight is boring because
maybe floyd can't inflict enough like
one punch damage
on logan so maybe it's boring and then
maybe he wins
in like the people's eyes because it's
like you actually went 10 rounds with
floyd mayweather
if floyd hurts him what what floyd does
is wears him out
and it makes him fight stiff and
uncomfortable because
he's body shots he's not going to be
nearly as efficient yeah logan is going
to be
much less efficient he's going to be
trying really hard
and he's never done i don't know how
many rounds they're doing how many
rounds are they doing
eight maybe or something i don't even
know if they've announced enough but
still
if i was floyd i'd wanted to be 12. yeah
the longer they dragged that guy into
deep water and then beat the [ __ ] out of
them because floyd can do 12 rounds in
his sleep
you can wake him up in the middle of the
night yeah so like if they were the same
size
it wouldn't even be interesting yeah and
even though logan's way bigger than him
it's still only mildly interesting yeah
because you literally have the greatest
boxer of all time
yeah versus a kid who's like really
athletic and really tough and
you can fight yeah but it's you know
he's he's not in that league
it's not no there's no no discussion
it's not a person on earth that thinks
he's in
the same league boxing yeah but floyd is
he's a true master master a master yeah
the greatest ever in my opinion
yes i would i would say he's in the
running like you
sugar ray robinson you just don't know a
hundred and something and oh
but you you and i was first live for
this like
like that's my dad's favorite boxer and
like my dad's a huge boxing fan he used
to like cover
boxing for the news he would go to ali's
camp like he has footage of like himself
like shadow boxing with ali
what yeah it's unbelievable and like if
anybody's a boxing
mob no no no he was he worked for nbc
really yeah he was like a newscaster
yeah yeah and like he just uh yeah he
did his wild story he's like forrest
gump he like did like the first ever
story on like hip hop music like
it was kind of crazy stuff but like he
uh he has a video like shadow boxing
with muhammad ali and muhammad ali
stops and goes what do you box oranges
so like he's the biggest ali fan in the
world and he saw you know sugar ray
robinson i guess when he was a kid
and he was like sugar ray robinson
outside of like him and ali those are
the best
i've ever seen but that's like a
generational thing obviously most boxers
like to point to sugar ray robinson as
the grace of all time yeah
guys who are in the know of boxing he
was a master
yeah he was awesome but he was a
different kind of master he would
slugged it out with people
he would get in there if he had to yeah
oh yeah yeah he fought rough and tumble
yeah but here's my argument against that
right he lost to jake lamotta in a
decision i can't imagine a world where
floyd mayweather loses to jake lamotta
if they're the same size i can't imagine
a world where floyd
doesn't outbox him because floyd has
this
he has a more intelligent approach and
his
his approach is to frustrate the [ __ ]
out of you and and take angles on you
and pop you and then
and then not let you hit him back and
then you get into fifth sixth seventh
round you start going
oh my god this is how this fight is
going i have to get desperate
i can't even hit this guy i dare you to
get done then you start getting down the
line yeah and then he
catches you like you caught ricky hatton
that's beautiful yeah check hook
yep yeah i mean he's just like watching
him just as like a boxing fan like
watching him take away people's
confidence
like i watched him take shane mosley's
confidence from him
like shane it did end up catching him
with that that right hand
right hand yeah and uh but what happened
was when shane i think threw his like
first or second jab
floyd had already timed him he threw the
first jab and then floyd came right over
the top he has that like amazing kind of
like slip and he comes right over the
top of the right hand
and he stunned shane and then right
after that shane was like i can't even
jab
there's nothing i can do this guy is on
a different level and he ended up
catching him with that right but still
like
yeah he's just it's just a great i don't
know what happened i mean i want logan
to get the money
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only
on spotify watch back catalog jre videos
on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience